hello everyone welcome to another
google+ hangout i'm really excited to
have my friend dan janelle from PR leads
with me here to talk about how to get
media attention and promote your
kickstarter campaign then welcome aboard
hey thanks it's great to be here and you
know I just can't say enough this is the
perfect time not 15 minutes ago I said I
pushed the button on a press release
announcing that we had funded our
campaign and knowing that we funded the
campaign in just three days a little bit
more than 48 hours from blast off to
finish line of course they're still
taking money but in 48 hours we reached
our goal so woohoo i'm uh i'm really
excited you got a good day all right
awesome so a little bit of background on
dane dance company is called PR leads is
para leads calm and they help
entrepreneurs get media attention and
it's an amazing service it's ninety nine
dollars a month and they send you daily
targeted list of reporters who are
working on stories and they need
credible experts to quote in their
stores and that's an entrepreneur you
should have the expertise right we
should all be experts in our business
and I got a lot of great results from PR
leads the first big one came when I got
new york times in integral New York
something new york times that's amazing
holy cow i loved him it's usually the
you know you got to do a lot of pitching
or you got to work with the publicist in
here it was this reporter from the New
York Times sent out a request or PR
leads and i responded and said hey let's
set up an interview and it was that easy
was pretty amazing um and have use it to
get Wall Street Journal and Forbes and a
bunch of other ones I guess it's a whole
list of reporters from different topics
different industries that are really
targeted so you can check it out at pier
leads calm and the link is in the
description as well and so today we're
talking about your business but also
Kickstarter how to get media attention
towards it so then tell us about the
campaign and congrats on hitting that
goal and in three days that's amazing
well thanks a lot this is great I don't
know if you're breaking up there but I
caught every every third
werd there and I think you want me to
talk about the Kickstarter campaign so I
will in just a few minutes I'll be happy
to take questions from your audience as
well you know basically here's the story
one of my clients came up with an idea
to peel garlic they have this product
all the garlic garlic shaker and it
peels garlic of efficiently effortlessly
uses high-tech it's it's really kind of
cool they got endorsements from
celebrity chefs and they started their
Kickstarter campaign and they want to me
to come in and help them promote the the
campaign which I did so we wrote a
series of press releases we sent out one
on the launch day and another one the
second day and a third one just now on
day three and they reach the goal and
that was really part of the plan we want
to get a lot of momentum because if you
get a lot of momentum Kickstarter takes
notice you're there are lots of
companies that want to get attention on
Kickstarter and it's a great great
service but they're like Amazon they
will promote the products that sell so
if you go to Amazon and you have a book
that's a hot seller you'll see that it's
on the front page of Amazon you'll front
page of Amazon for you know a certain
genre same with products that they like
it could be batteries or ink cartridges
and something is selling they'll put it
in a position where everyone will see it
well Kickstarter uses the exact same
idea so if you get off to a fast start
they'll put you on the front page of
their website or the front page of their
website for the different categories
this one happens to be food so after the
first day they were in the number one
position on the front page for the food
category so anyone who's looking for a
food product or to fund a food product
or whatever couldn't help but notice the
garlic shaker and also they were number
17 overall of all the Kickstarter
promotions and other thousands of
promotions in any given time but they
ranked number 17 because of publicity
because of social media because of all
the things they did and I don't want to
blow my own horn here you know PR is
important but it's part of the marketing
mix and these guys work their butts off
in a lot of different ways to get to the
number one position and to engage their
audience but PR helped helped kick the
can down the road and get them into
search engines and get them onto
newspapers and get them onto media
websites that led to more traffic we
actually have proof that it's it because
we could see who clicked on or how many
p
clicked on the releases we could see the
number of contributions that's what the
call to call donors and contributions
they're not called buyers and sales
because just the way Kickstarter works
with their own terminology so we could
actually see that the numbers increase
when the press releases went out we
could see the numbers increase when
people click on the videos it was all
very algorithm driven and all very
scientific and I can't say enough about
it it's a wonderful feeling to make your
goal because a lot of companies don't
make their goals at all or they make it
just at the last minute um but here's
the case we're in literally just a
little bit more than 48 hours we were
able to raise the $25,000 that they
needed to to launch their campaign and
go on to the next steps of their
manufacturing and production cycle
awesome so how much how much were they
trying to raise they were trying to
raise twenty five thousand dollars for I
believe the fabrication of their their
product and then you know there are
other there are other levels that they
need to reach internally to for
inventory for distribution whatever me
this is a real company that has real
products and real people working for
them and they have a big plan work out
so you just don't go on shark tank one
day and turn around and sell a billion
dollars worth of stuff there's a lot of
work that has to be done in terms of
like creating an actual product they
this is actually it's kind of a funny
thing you know it's technology because I
think how do you pay how'd you shake how
do you peel garlic what's this garlic
shaker what's the deal well they have
this like hourglass shaped little tube
that you shake it inside there are these
wires that they have figured out with
physics on where they hit the shells of
the garlic and where hits the skin and
where would separate and how many times
you have to shake it for this action to
happen I mean this is real size so real
physics they had real brains working on
this you know people who are designed I
don't want to say the Space Telescope
but there are people who are like really
high up in physics who knew what they're
doing with art and design and physics to
make all of this happen to do a simple
thing like peeling garlic which
apparently is not very simple because if
it were simple they would have done it a
million years ago by apparently chefs
you know get smelly hands they they cut
themselves with knives trying to peel
the garlic so it's a safe way of doing
it apparently America loved it too
because they put their money where their
mouth is and they bought 25 thousand
dollars worth of these things so it's
again it's pretty cool i'm on a high yes
i ask you some questions this is fun
good so so so it's great insider ready
it's like day one launch you want to
have some attention you want to be able
to drive awareness and drive some sales
that you get featured on the page so
leading up to that there's obviously a
lot of work and if you're doing stuff in
the media you want them to notice you
what walk me through that process what
do you have to do so that on day one
when your kickstarter campaign launches
there are people talking about you and
talk about your part what you did on the
media you're cutting okay that's a great
question you're also kind of cutting out
there i don't know if it's my connection
or whatever but when you go back and
listen to this again okay if you need to
clean up anything let me know okay uh
what has to be done beforehand well you
need a whole team it's like a Hillary
Clinton said you need a village there
are a lot of lot of moving parts they
had more than 40,000 people signed up on
their Facebook page do you believe if
this approach it does not even really
exist yet it's in their minds I but yet
they were active on Facebook and they
got 40,000 people who were interested in
this and maybe they went after chefs
groups or cooking groups and whatever
but they really beat the bushes their
second and I'm sure anyone who's been on
the receiving end of a Kickstarter
campaign or an IndieGoGo campaign or any
of the other kinds of crowd funding
services knows this you get emails from
people i mean i got an email about a
month and a half ago from someone whose
name sounds vaguely familiar and i
thought it might be spam but it was like
familiar enough that i feel like i just
opened it anyway and said hey dan
remember me we worked on ashton Tate
together it was like my god that was
1995 that was 20 years ago we have not
talked in 20 years and yet he reached
out to me and said hey I'm the project
manager for this new company we're doing
a Kickstarter campaign for this kind of
you know was like a television device
and it was like so he reached out to
people 20 years back in his email in
fact it was part of an email string and
I could scroll down and see that the the
emails from literally 1995 and
ironically it was 20 years ago to the
day when we
letest exchanged an email so I think if
you're doing a Kickstarter campaign or
an IndieGoGo or anything like that there
is no shame you go after anyone and
everyone in your database in fact my
wife got a request on like farmer's
funding farmers whatever uh one of her
friends sons bought a farm in Maine and
he needed some funding so went to this
farm funding site and he reached out to
all of theirs friends so there is no
shame in asking for money you're going
hat in hand and you're going to people
you have this phone to a 20 years you're
going after your friends you're going
after your relatives you're going after
people haven't spoken from in 20 years
in fact one of my cousin's was an MFA
graduate student at Columbia she's put
together a funding for a film and you
know she that was on an IndieGoGo it's
about three thousand seven months ago
she actually got her funding was like 20
grand that she wanted and but it was
like a daily barrage of emails was like
leave me alone already I I gave you
money you want more money ah so you
might risk some friendships along there
but hey she's my cousin and I love her
so it was cool and she actually made the
film it actually appeared at South by
Southwest so it's a pretty good film um
so you could be part of something that
is really really important and I think
that's kind of the fun thing as a donor
that yo your name is listed on the
credits or you might get a product or
you might get the product at a deep
discount because you're one of the early
people or you just like the idea of what
the company is doing so you support it
but the company itself it's this endless
endless series of emails in fact I asked
my client you know I'm going this tell
some of this afternoon what one piece of
advice would you would you give people
you know what what was the one key to
your success and he said number one was
getting off to a fast launch so you get
on the front page of Kickstarter so they
promote you and he said that thirty
three percent of their donations came
after the first day were traced back to
Kickstarter so your friends your
families your facebook friends your
followers you're going on your platform
get you onto the front page and then
Kickstarter kicks in and they do a lot
of the heavy lifting for you and
probably it's all automatic because
people are going to the site and they're
seeing it automatically but if you're in
that front page two-thirds of your work
is done this Kickstarter again raised
about a third
they're funding which is pretty cool so
well is if I could share that and he
said he's all about transparency so
we're all cool with that I would never
divulge company secrets otherwise of
course but yeah so it was a massive
social media campaign lots of the emails
I said did you send out emails he said
constantly 24 hours a day so it really
is it's a lot of work but apparently it
pays off to one of the questions is that
they want to know what the name of the
film was ah the name of the film I buy
something like this it's like whatever
doesn't kill you like the kelly clarkson
song whatever doesn't kill you makes you
stronger so whatever doesn't kill you
and my cousin's name is Hannah Janelle
JK nal and was at South by Southwest
just in the last couple of months so
it's out there I don't know how it's
being distributed or anything like that
but they made the film which is pretty
cool especially if you're a graduate
student at Columbia so more power to her
cool so then how do you use the media to
help boost your Kickstarter campaign
well if the media writes about your
product you know that's that's that's
super cool great but the first step is
you send out a press release and we use
PR newswire because it really is
effective in getting attention on the
search engines and that's really a key
thing here because there are a lot of
free press release websites out there
and frankly they don't generate a whole
lot of traffic or interest or search
engine optimization we've been doing
this for a number of years now and built
up a specialty in this and we like using
PR newswire because we found that
frankly their links get indexed better
than the others and ironically my client
went behind my back and whose business
wire and PR web in addition to PR
newswire on the first day so they didn't
tell me about that they didn't know they
were supposed to tell me about that but
you know they did it anyway so here's my
first real test of using the same press
release going out on the same day on
three different services so we could see
which ones get picked up more more
readily and more more actively and more
importantly which one's Google likes to
index more and in a lot of cases it was
PR newswire we got out there first
it was picked up on more than 200 media
websites we've used them for the last
two days as well to get additional
traffic and additional search engine
listings for various topics like bears
keywords like kitchen gadget hot kitchen
gadget new kitchen gadgets kitchen tools
garlic peelers see how to peel garlic
whatever so we done our keyword research
there and we showed up pretty well there
too uh what we also did was we got
started getting inquiries from reporters
at Food Network's mean we we did a
campaign actually reaching out to
individual reporters who are private
databases to food of food reporters
catering reporters restaurant magazines
and such and wait about 200 people open
the press release is about database
about 1500 food reporters about 200 open
the the press release and about 25 of
those actually clicked on the link going
to the Kickstarter campaign so we now
know that there are two groups of active
reporters who are interested to a
certain degree in this product and again
it's not ready for review it's already
for sale so we're going to be able to
follow up with them and we're talking
about reporters literally from the New
York Times the Food Network I could name
some famous chefs like Alton Brown I
actually read the press release and
other people from the Food Network and
other big food bloggers and food writers
and reviewers so we're actually able to
pull out the names of reporters that
will follow up with for the next phase
of this campaign so obviously well I
wish that they were in a position to
write daily blogs about hot new stuff
but I don't think they are so this will
help us in the next phase when the
product was actually ready for review
and for purchase and for sale on the web
and in retail stores and such like that
and they've already been contacted by
the Oscars and the Emmys to be in their
gift bags mean these people are
connected which always helps your
campaign they had celebrity chefs do
endorsements for the product and that
was on the Kickstarter sales page or I
don't think they call it a sales page
occult you know the you know the program
page the page that introduces you to the
product which frankly is a whole
industry unto itself there's a video
there's a long sales letter but you have
to be
you know there's a whole way of doing
this and certain do's and don'ts for
being successful obviously but
Kickstarter has all figured out in the
they want to work in your favor so they
tell you what what works and how to do
things which is really great um but
again for the next phase of our PR
campaign we now know 20 reporters at top
places who are interested in this
product was to click through on the
Kickstarter link and another 200
reporters who at least read the press
release which is at least an indication
of interest so we can go back to them
and say hey we know you're interested or
you know what can we do to help you
you
evident I know you dropped out or I
dropped out I'm trying to get back in